Michael we're at PAX West 2019 and we
just got to play Link's Awakening the
remake coming to Nintendo switch later
this month it looks pretty cool yes
pretty cute
after getting actually playing it you
know it's a it's that classic 2d Zelda
vibe as you would expect because Link's
Awakening this is a a full-on remake of
that original Gameboy game but of course
with a much more modern art style or
well with a with a cutesy art style
would say I think this game has a lot of
charm to it just by the looks of it you
know if you had especially for those who
may pull only played modern Zelda's the
3d ones especially breath of the wild
that's a very different thing you know I
think this is gonna be a real treat for
those who haven't experienced a 2d
top-down Zelda and it's just the it's a
real pleasure to play yeah any new
people who like there's a huge following
for this game people love this game it's
like the cult classic of Zelda games
that it just cuz it's so weird and like
we go into a 2d section where there's a
piranha plant but once again that's
pretty standard fare cuz we're playing
the key cavern which they haven't shown
off before but you know if you've played
the original will be very familiar one
thing they pointed out to us is that all
of the dungeons in this game are
one-to-one recreations of the original
so even though it looks much prettier
and cute if you've played the the Link's
Awakening on Gameboy recently or 3ds
whatever you're playing on it would be
very familiar
even though this is a recreation of the
old Gameboy game it still feels fresh to
me for some reason like the way they do
puzzles and you know some of the powers
and how they manifest as solutions for
the things that you need to do is that's
still that's still there I mean I think
that's kind of why 2d Zelda ZAR timeless
is because you know all the clever ways
that they create dungeons and they go
have different conditions to defeat
enemies like there's just like a lot of
neat challenges throughout these
dungeons you know just because this is a
remake of an old game doesn't mean it
simple is it weird going back to a 2d
Zef to playing a lot of breath of the
wild the first few minutes it did feel a
little strange like oh I haven't engaged
with this this sort of style in a while
but you know well once you get your
bearings it's a you know you kind of I
remember what it was like to play a Link
to the Past and other 2d top-down Zelda
games and you know it's refreshing it's
kind of nice fighting bosses like this
again you know I have to breath of the
wild where you know you there was some
weapons in breath well you had to use to
take down certain bosses that would make
it easier to take out certain enemies
but having bosses with like oh basically
puzzle bosses with a very specific way
to beat them is a lot of fun granted
this guy's this guy wasn't too tough
yeah like you said we did it our first
try however I think they did get pretty
close yeah it's once you figure out the
ways to beat the boss then it's kind of
you know not so you you do what you need
to do but getting there is a whole
nother thing especially here when they
the two pieces jump up and stun you if
you don't if you don't jump before they
hit the ground that was like a neat
touch in there to you know make you
think about more variables with in this
game you know you're not just slashing
you're not just throwing bombs yeah they
can trip you up too because the first
one comes down pretty easy to avoid but
if you don't make the jump you're gonna
get stunned and crushed and I just made
that jump but I still got crushed by
that yeah look you have less than two
hearts right there but yeah so you know
Link's Awakening isn't playing around
anyway that's what we saw of the Link's
Awakening remake it comes a Nintendo
switch on September 20th and for more
pack stuff stay tuned GameSpot
[Music]
[Music]